es ist die hammer meldungen zu corona
und sie könnte die pandemie politik in
deutschland und sogar weltweit auf den
kopf stellen ganz genau laut einer
aktuellen studie aus den usa nämlich
sind blog downs komplett wirkungslos sie
hätten keine toten verhindert sondern
ausschließlich negative folgen heißt es
auch grants und schulschließungen sind
laut dieser studie völlig sinnlos es ist
ernst bleiben sie zu hause wir erinnern
uns frühjahr 2020 knall hatte lok da uns
in ganz europa und in den usa wochen
lang lag während der ersten corona welle
alles lahm menschenleere straßen alle
mussten zu hause bleiben aber diese
krassen maßnahmen hatten laut einer
neuen studie fast keinen effekt auf die
anzahl der cholera toten das haben jetzt
drei wissenschaftler der renommierten
johns hopkins universität mit hilfe
einer großen analyse herausgefunden
das ergebnis ganz konkret die todesrate
wurde durch die loks in europa und den
usa nur um 0,2 prozent gesenkt im
einzelnen betrachtet keine
schulschließungen haben die
sterblichkeitsrate nur um 0,1 prozent
gesenkt
grenzschließungen haben sie gar keinen
effekt deutlich effektiver waren zum
beispiel aber masten am arbeitsplatz
dadurch wurde die zahl der krone toten
um 24 prozent reduziert die schließung
von clubs und bars hat sich auch
deutlich ausgewirkt die zahl der
cholera-toten reduzierte sich um weitere
15 prozent
lockt downs hatten wenig oder keine
wirkung auf die mortalität das hat auch
der virologe klaus stöhr und genau
darüber wollen wir jetzt mit ihm
sprechen guten tag herr stöhr verändert
diese studie jetzt auch die politik ja
das kann ich nicht beurteilen da müssen
sie die politiker fragen aber ich würde
mir gut vorstellen dass die ergebnisse
der studie sicherlich hoffentlich in
zukunft auch einen einfluss haben zu der
sicherheit der studie
müssen wir noch einiges hinzufügen
welche großen meter studien bei denen
man also einzelne studien aus sehr
vielen ländern von argentinien südkorea
vielen europäischen ländern usa
verglichen hat haben natürlich ihre
stärken und ihre schwächen und die
größte stärke besteht sicherlich daran
dass man trends und tendenzen ableiten
kann aber man kann nicht die dritte
stelle hinterm komma verwenden was die
mathematische analyse betrifft oder das
sagen die autoren ja auch explizit also
es wichtig hier mitzunehmen dass die lok
da uns die
dort umgesetzt von den verschiedenen
ländern nicht den effekt hatten den dich
viele vorgestellt haben das ist aber
auch keine große überraschung da gab es
auch schon viele andere publikationen
vor der pandemie die darauf hinwiesen
auch in deutschland haben 2003 daten
umfassende studie publiziert
2016/17 im deutschen pandemieplan einen
anhang gibt es auch eine große liste
dieser sogenannten den pharmatitel
intervention ist sie eigentlich in ihrer
wirkung unbekannt sind also es gibt
viele dieser diese 0,2 prozent die von
erwähnt haben ich würde mich daran nicht
festhalten aber was man sicherlich sagen
kann ist die autoren konnten nicht
belegen dass es einen zusammenhang gibt
zwischen der stärke der loddar uns und
der reduktion der mortalität also das
sind sicherlich dinge die man mitnehmen
muss aber nicht vergessen also diese
kontakt beschränkung bleiben wichtig
auch für die zukunft muss sie nur
dosieren und wichtig war auch sicherlich
dass die autoren gesehen haben dass die
unterschiede zwischen deutschen lockdown
die
imitation als pflicht und mit denen die
als
freiwillig organisationen dass es da
keinen unterschied gab also man kann
also mit ähnlichen mitteln ohne zwang
unter umständen das gleiche oder sogar
mehr erreichen die studie sagt auch dass
schulschließungen zum beispiel und auch
grenzschließungen völlig wirkungslos
waren nun sind locker und
grenzschließungen aktuell ja nun gar
nicht im gespräch bei den
schulschließungen ist das noch ein
bisschen anders die müssen ja nun jetzt
wirklich tatsächlich auch vom tisch
seien nach dieser studie oder das würde
ich hoffe dass hätte ich gehofft von
anfang an der pandemie als ich 2003 mit
kollegen in china waren tiere die stars
aus wochen angeschaut habe waren wir
sehr erstaunt dass die kinder fast nicht
beteiligt waren an diesem ausbruch das
hat eigentlich schon ein starker hinweis
sein müsste eigentlich für
2019 und 2020
das musste man sicherlich überprüfe aber
die daten wurden dann ja auch relativ
schnell international zusammen getan ist
die kinder ich möchte das wort verwenden
keine treiber der pandemie waren und
sind das die infektions richtung in die
andere
richtung hat geht von dem kind von den
erwachsenen zu den kindern und das wurde
aber in deutschland glaube ich am
wenigsten international wahrgenommen und
auch inkludiert ich meine die schweizer
auch die franzosen haben die schulen
dann nicht mehr geschlossen bzw nur in
sehr begrenztem umfang haben diese daten
berücksichtigt in deutschland ist das
vollständig an der pandemie entscheidung
vorbei gegangen man hat so immer zuerst
oder häufig zuerst auf die kinder
gespielt wenn es darum ging die
maßnahmen sie mussten ja auch verstärkt
werden vor der winter werden aber hat
man immer zuerst die kinder geschieht
und gefühlt hat man auch 80 prozent über
die kinder diskutiert und nicht darüber
dass eben die wellen geschützt wird man
darf die kinder natürlich vergessen aber
man hat die wohlhabenden aus meinem
blickwinkel zu stark nach hinten
gedrängt in der diskussion und auch bei
den maßnahmen und da braucht man sich
nicht wundern wenn jetzt ja 40 prozent
der todesfälle im letzten winter bei
diesen willen haben den
altenpflegeheimen vanek relativ kleinen
gruppe also da gibt es viele dinge die
man lernen kann und lernen muss ich
hoffe wirklich dass das langsam auch in
die pandemie bekämpfung aktiv überführt
wird
hersteller sollte die also die 2g regel
soll ja in schleswig-holstein gekippt
werden dänemark schafft fast alle corona
maßnahmen ab sollte deutschland auch
endlich lockern was raten sie also doch
kann muss man so wie sich die situation
verändert wird er nicht schlagartig
jetzt
anthony werden also muss man auch
stufenweise deeskalieren und zum damit
anfangen da bei den maßnahmen die am
wenigsten effizient sind und wo die
evidenz am höchsten ist dass sie keine
wirkung erzeugen das ist für mich zweig
plus und zweig es ist ja nicht nur so
dass der einzelhandel darunter leidet
ist hat ja auch keine wirkung wenn man
den zahlen glauben kann es hat ja keinen
großen ausbruch wie im letzten zwei
jahren im einzelhandel bei den
mitarbeitern noch bei den kunden warum
soll man das schließen und ist natürlich
auch schwierig zu vermitteln an die
geimpften dass sie sich jetzt noch mal
testen lassen müssen wenn sie einkaufen
gehen sollen und letztendlich ist ja
eigentlich in der genese und
geimpfte das normale
set für die zukunft so ritz allem gehe
ich also da muss man anfangen zweig +2
geben einem restaurant sicherlich muss
man auch die quarantäne nachdenken in
norwegen auch in dänemark spricht man
darüber dass man die container abschafft
auch in anderen denn dann macht sich ja
keinen sinn wir auch bei uns nicht weil
50 prozent derjenigen die in frankreich
dann kommen schon und positiv getestet
werden auch aus anderen gründen dahin
genannte des virus zirkuliert frei
außerdem muss man ein stückchen für
stückchen die richtigen stellschrauben
betätigen ohne natürlich jetzt gleich
alles öffnen zu müssen oder zu wollen
schleswig-holstein glaube ich mache das
ganz wichtig sagt der virologe klaus
steuer dankeschön dass er sich die zeit
genommen haben ich bedanke mich
fast zwei jahre haben wir uns mit lok
downs mit schulschließungen und
reiseverboten und et cetera noch
ungeschlagen ja und jetzt ja bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder der
schlägt plötzlich ganz neue töne an vom
team vorsicht zum team mutig
seit 317 tagen kennen wir markus söder
als den corona hardliner auf einer skala
von 0 bis 10 0 keine probleme 10 totale
apokalypse wo befinden wir uns in
deutschland
naja so bei 9 würde ich sagen wenn sie
das mit zehn apokalypse sind bei 9 wenn
wir merken ja wie die krankenhäuser
volllaufen wirklich vor laufen deswegen
brauchen wir nahezu flächendeckend zweig
so wie es in bayern jetzt auch machen
auch zwei gehen der gast wo für alle
bereiche zweig ist team vorsicht hat
insgesamt sich durchgesetzt und zwar bei
allen
wir wissen dass krone bleischwer über
dem land liegt und das ist uns alle
beschwert doch gestern schlug der
bayerische ministerpräsident
plötzlich ganz andere töne an
hoffnungsvollere zukunft brauchen wir
neben dem konzept vorsicht auch das
konzept augenmaß und hoffnung wir
brauchen einen stufenplan wie wir den
nächsten wochen tatsächlich
erleichterungen durchführen können und
darüber wollen wir jetzt mit ralf
schuler sprechen er ist leiter des bild
parlamentsbüros ralf woher kommt nun
soll das umschwung
ja markus söder ist ein
instinktpolitiker das war schon immer
wir erinnern uns hat vor nicht mal zwei
drei jahren noch kruzifixe in amtsstuben
aufgehängt dann hat der bäume umarmt war
erst der härteste corona bekämpfer jetzt
ist er der erste der sich an die spitze
der eröffnungs bewegung stellen will mit
einem konkreten plan
nimmt einfach zur kenntnis dass zum teil
die krone müdigkeit im land umgeht und
andererseits eben auch das weißen sogar
unsere eigenen umfragen auch aus die
angst vor ansteckung deutlich abnimmt
weil durch die impfung kroner anteil
seines schreckens verloren hat und da
ist das nicht länger vertretbar die
krankenhäuser laufen eben nicht mehr
voll es gibt zwar noch erhöhte
behandlungszahlen aber es ist nicht mehr
so dramatisch wie es dort geschildert
hatte und da will er selbstverständlich
auch mit blick auf seine eigenen
landtagswahlen im kommenden jahr nicht
als der ihn ja da stehen der den
menschen das leben schwer macht
was heißt das jetzt ganz konkret können
wir damit rechnen dass in bayern jetzt
in den nächsten tagen gelockert wird
ja ganz so schnell wird es noch nicht
gehen es gibt zwar erste
bestrebungen etwa in gaststätten die 2g
regel abzuschaffen oder deutlich zu
erleichtern es gibt die ersten das hat
er mir gestern auch hier erzählt bei der
klausur der csu landesgruppe in berlin
es gibt die pläne mehr menschen in
kulturveranstaltungen und
sportstadien zu lassen und dann auf
abstand zu achten das alkoholverbot soll
bleiben aber es sollen deutlich mehr
menschen dort wieder zugang haben und
auch im einzelhandel reicht in vielen
fällen die maske sagt er und genau das
soll so einen stufenplan werden der dann
spätestens bei der nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mitte
februar mit den anderen länderchefs
gesprochen wird und nach und nach dann
umgesetzt wird es ist immer ganz gut
drauf zu achten wenn politik etwas
ankündigt wie konkret der fahrplan
genannt wird und der war noch etwas
weich und noch nicht allzu festgezurrt
dass ich gehe davon aus dass mitte
februar mit den ersten lockerungen
begonnen wird und dann in den märz
hinein auch mit blick auf die
landtagswahlen im saarland und in
nordrhein westfalen im mai die
lockerungen um wirklich umgesetzt werden
wie ist denn die stimmung auf der csu
klausurtagung
die stimmung ist eigentlich ganz
ausgelassen die der staat der ampel
regierung wird als größte
oppositionspartei bei der union als
fehlstart interpretiert der start des
neuen cdu-chefs friedrich merz der heute
hier auch vorbeikommen wird und
sozusagen den fahrplan zur rückeroberung
der macht mit markus söder besprechen
wird der staat ist eigentlich ganz gut
gelungen eine tolle unterstützung von
der cdu-basis bekommen das ist jetzt
auch in der briefwahl noch mal bestätigt
worden man ist schulter an schulter mit
der csu gemeinsam auf dem weg die
ampelkoalition unter feuer zu nehmen hat
ja auch ein großes papier verabschiedet
was man alles fordert das geht bis zu
einer flexi woche und einer für home
office und bis hin zu einer flat tax für
den mittelstand also man hat viele gute
ideen die man derzeit weder bezahlen
noch umsetzen muss und man hat ist
eigentlich guter dinge jetzt
durchzustarten und die oppositionsarbeit
wirklich aufzunehmen und sich auf die
ampel mehr und mehr einzuschiessen
sagt der leiter des bild parlamentsbüros
vielen dank für das gespräch